I'm Logan Paul I'm date unless we're
outside of the fitting I'm Logan ball
I'm being list and we're on the center
and thinner yeah
I'm Logan Pole I'm painless yeah even
killed by now you got this hey what's up
I'm Logan Paul I'm Caitlin and we're
outside of the Finnick and you're
watching easy online perfect well if you
don't support our Great Society then you
are a parasite
do you know what we do with parasites
we wash them out the biggest surprise
about making a movie has got to be the
weights in between takes I'm so used to
doing stuff in a scrimmage I'm fast on
the go and just calming down being
patient for me has become something I
have yet to get used to when uh Leah
Murray Johnson was where I sit at lunch
she's like she's like I hung gree I'm
gonna go grab another cookie and I was
on I was on my like third day of the
juice cleanse and sometimes I say stuff
like to convince myself I don't need
food and I was like look you don't need
a cookie but not like oh it was bad the
girls like oh good what it was like I
[Music]
wouldn't say anything too freaky has
happened but I will say looking at these
guards dressed up in just like all black
lines Anton's Rao's was a that's just
fried Twinkie alone take her to the
theater yeah it's terrifying yeah I
would say sweet Payton little bacon
Lissa's sweet we're not Lena Michaels
everyone into my closet she's she's in
Ted she's determined but I would say
you're very motivated person we are
working oh thank you thank you I would
say a really cool thing is to see Logan
and I outside of that comedic area to
see us in a really serious part yeah and
beyond that kids you know every year are
getting eliminated if they don't pass a
test hopefully that doesn't happen in
real life but this movie addresses that
problem pretty spot-on
are we approved to commence the penny
you are approved
[Music]
you